so cryptography is the idea of
encrypting a message so but although
everyone knows a message has been sent
they can't actually find out what it
means
whereas in steganography we're trying to
hide the fact that we send a message at
all so a classic example would be if I
was writing you a letter and then I
wrote an invisible ink a whole different
letter between the lines or on the other
side or something like that and only you
knew that that was going to be there so
you get home and everyone else maybe
looks at the letter and think that's not
very interesting at all and then of
course you can uncover the secret
message today we'll talk a bit about
digital image steak and ography because
obviously there's a huge scope for
hiding things and digital images images
can be megabytes or more and you can
hide files of megabytes or more in them
but of course as the the amount of
steganography in images has increased so
as the attempts to try and find it so
there's lots of statistical approaches
to try and find these things as well
perhaps the most simple form of
steganography an image it's least
significant bit
steganography so if we've got a bitmap
of any kind of PNG or BMP then we can
change the lowest bits to be our message
and it'll have an almost imperceptible
change on the actual way the image looks
it's a bit like if I changes number
eight hundred thousand three hundred and
fifty-one if I change the wall or the 51
on that it's not gonna have a massive
that's exactly right the day number is
so big that in the grand scheme of
things it makes no difference so
generally speaking will change in the
image every single byte will change the
last bit or maybe the last two bits if
we're really trying to cram in a lot of
data every byte is eight bits we take
the last two and change that to our
message in the hope that no one's going
to notice so for every byte that's every
eight bits six of them are the regular
image and two of them are our secret
message so a quarter of our message is
now secret so if we have a normal pixel
it's going to be four bytes long so
that's one byte so for each byte we're
talking about the last two bits in that
byte so that could be a one we could
change it to a one change up to a zero
or leave them both the same and what we
do is we read off our message so let's
say our message we're trying to equip
is one zero one one zero one okay we get
to the first bite and we say well this
is great our first two bites are already
one and zero so we don't need to change
anything at all so that by it stays as
it is so we go to the next pipe so this
would be maybe B red and this might be
green in our pixel okay the last two
bits of this bite are zero and one that
the two we're trying to put in from our
message are 1 and 1 so we change this
one to a 1 so by changing that second
least significant bit from 0 to 1 we've
just increased this value by 2 and we're
talking about a 1 channel in a huge
image changing by 2 levels it's probably
not going to be too noticeable
if we start changing the higher
significance bits then that might be a
problem all right so I've written a
program to do this and I've tried to
hide a rather large file inside another
rather large image okay so this is a
nice picture of a tree it's about
feeling a bit megapixels in size so this
is the original image of our tree and
that is for steganographic image first
one and two the second one well it's not
changing it is changing when you only
change the last two significant bits of
an 8 bits per channel image you're not
going to see a huge amount of detail if
you actually do a subtraction on images
you can see a difference but in general
it's going to be pretty imperceptible
but the really good thing to do would be
to never release the original source
image I can tell but something's change
because I've got the original and the
new steganographic image with me but if
I just sent out an image of my dog and I
never sent out the original but the
camera took no one's going to know that
it's been imperceptibly changed because
they haven't got a reference if you take
a public domain image and change it it's
going to be easy to look for the
original source exactly the other thing
is it'll work better on photographs
where there's a lot of variation in the
intensity levels anyway so this
steganographic image has the entire
works of Shakespeare buried in it which
comes to when it zipped up about 1/2
Meg's something like that this kind of
simple steganography can be detected
this image here is an image that i've
created by taking only the last two bits
of each channel I've scrapped all the
other information if a pixel has a value
of naught it's black if it has a value
of 3 it's white and then it ranges in
between and you can see if it is a
truther okay so you can see even in the
first two bits but there's a
and the skies particularly bland so if
you look instead at the steganographic
image I've done the same filter to that
and you can see but the amount of noise
has increased massively because that
noise is all hidden in those least two
significant bits so you can see if you
compare the bits from one HD other you
can see a difference and so hiding a
messaging Mele significant bits it's
fairly obvious particularly if you have
the original for comparison so this is
the difference between those two images
where and I've massively scaled up the
difference I mean it looks very gray
these white pixels and black pixels are
values of plus or minus 3 intensity
changes so we're still talking very
small differences over the image and
it's very evenly distributed it's all
sort of spread noisily out throughout
the image yes you can't actually tells a
true you know you can't tell there's a
tree there which could be a clue perhaps
a more sophisticated method of hiding
something an image would be to hide it
inside the discrete cosine transform
coefficients of a JPEG so we talked a
little bit about the DCT and how we
convert an image into a series of cosine
waves and we have coefficients saying
how much of each of those waves we have
if you change those coefficients instead
of changing or pixel values you have a
much less predictable effect on the
image if you change the value of V of
one of the alternating current large or
open current coefficients from two
hundred to two hundred and one you're
going to have a very imperceptible
difference and it's going to happen over
that entire eight-way block so you're
not going to be able to see the clear
sort of steganographic noise that we
just looked at on that tree a common
algorithm that we're seeing use is
called J steg so I see what they did
there and and what j stick does is it
goes in and if it can it will cram the
discrete cosine transform coefficients
full of as much data as it can and what
it does is any coefficients are 0 or 1
because they might change and be a
little bit obvious
so usually below frequency ones might
change up or down and you can see again
that the difference is almost
imperceptible so here's a picture of
panda and what I've done here I couldn't
cram in as much information before so
it's just Macbeth in this one so there's
the original and a steganographic image
and I've looked at these and I created a
difference and you can see that again
it's
very very very slight so these pixels
again have only changed by plus or minus
three maybe one maybe two that's just
assumed that's zoomed in on the
difference right there so you can see
that yes the pixels of change but
they've not changed by a lot and the
other crucial thing about hiding your
message in the discrete cosine transform
coefficients the JPEG is already
completely messed up the least
significant bits of your image so if you
do an image like I did where we're
looking at just the bits we will no
longer be able to see a tree we'll just
be able to see very general JPEG noise
and that will be exactly the same in our
steganographic image so you can't do
what they call a visual attack by
looking and seeing if it's a
steganographic message hidden inside
because there's no no real change so
this is the original and I'm only
showing here the least two significant
bits and you can see that they form into
little blocks and these were blocks as
the 8x8 discrete cosine transform blocks
and this is the steganographic data so
you can see what be the blocks have
changed but the distribution of noise
throughout the image hasn't changed at
all so it's very difficult to say
there's a message bowed in there and if
the message took up only a certain
amount of the image it's hard to see
where in this image the message is you
could be trying to read off every
discrete cosine transform coefficient
when in fact only some of them have a
messaging if you were sending this to
someone as a message yeah how would they
don't they get it out okay so in general
you would also encrypt the message
because you know you better be safe and
sorry why not use encryption so we
encrypt our message we put it in
discrete cosine transform coefficients
or in the least significant bits and
then we send it off to someone now
they're going to have to have known the
process we used because if they don't
they're gonna be looking in the wrong
place so they'll know they'll know that
we used J steg or f5 or one of the other
DCT steganography tools then them and
they'll basically run the program
they'll type in their decryption key
which will actually remove the
encryption and then out comes their
message when J Steg was invented it was
robust to visual attack so you couldn't
look at it and go well back clearly it's
been altered so they had to try and come
up with researchers had to try and come
up with some other way of detecting but
an image has had a J steak message
buried in it and what in what end up
what in fact happened
is that the coefficients change ever so
slightly because we're applying
quantization to our DCT coefficients
most of them will be set to zero
okay and J steak won't put anything in
there because it's too obvious they'll
only put them in a few every top corner
but a big and you'll find that the
there's a subtle imbalance produced in
where your coefficients loss you're
expecting most of your coefficients to
be zero and then a fair few of them to
be minus 1 or 1 and minus 2 and 2 to be
very close to zero and in fact you start
to get a few fries and Falls that you
weren't expecting and the distribution
of these numbers goes off a little bit
and you can start to predict what the J
steak image a steak file has been buried
inside what's more is that this happens
in each 8 by 8 block so you can actually
do this test on every block and find out
which blocks have messages in and which
blocks don't and you might find for
example with the first 60% of a file has
a message in and then it abruptly stops
and that's a blatant clue that we've got
something but isn't taking up the whole
image it's just been read written
sequentially into the file so if we take
the frequency of the number of
occurrences of each discrete cosine
transform coefficient so naught is going
to be the most common there may be minus
1 and 1 and we plot those in a graph
with frequency on the y-axis and the
discrete cosine coefficient on the
x-axis we get what's called a histogram
and that's simply a plot of the
frequency of occurrences of various
things so you can do a histogram on an
image but you can also do a histogram on
these DCT coefficients and find out
whether they've been imperceptibly
changed once people started routinely
detecting J stig other people came along
and decided well that's you know is too
obvious let's try and make it a little
bit more subtle so what they did was
they wrote discrete cosine transform a
steganography approaches where they pay
attention to the statistics of the
coefficients and try and keep them
balanced so if you put in a 1 you try
and take one out somewhere else so that
you keep the histogram and the
probabilities of these coefficients
occurring at the same and that makes it
much harder to use your standard
histogram analysis technique to find out
whether there's anything in the image
but now what they can do with the power
of machine learning is take let's say a
thousand images
ten of which may or may not have
something buried inside and a classifier
will pretty well find out which ones
they are you just have to have a lot of
positive and negative samples to throw
it all sound wonderful but you know come
war zones and everything who she's
juicing these techniques well yeah so
aside from spies I should say I'm not
using these techniques you know anyone's
everyone watch him exactly so I think
one of the most common uses is digital
walk at watermarking so in normal
steganography what we want to do is try
and hide a message as well as possible
and then all it really matters it a
person on the other side can get it and
no one else really notices in
watermarking what we want to try and do
is fingerprint a file so that we know
where it came from we know it's ours
maybe for copyright reasons or to trace
who's been distributing illegal material
and the key to a watermark is instead of
it being as much payload as possible so
instead of trying to crown the entire
works of Shakespeare into an image what
you should be doing is just a small
let's say small logo or a small piece of
text repeated over and over so that if
the image gets cropped or the image gets
read compressed it's still there and you
can imagine that stock photo companies
might do this to try and make sure that
people aren't distributing their files
elsewhere and you can imagine or that
they would troll through the web looking
for steganographic images embedded in
their particular way another case you
might find if you were if you were
distributing pre-release DVDs of a film
and then it gets leaked onto the
Internet if there's stigma graphic data
on the source buried in you better see
who was it leaked it file contained each
file could be tailored with the person
that they originally sent that file to
and then when that particular file finds
their way onto internet that person is
going to be in trouble
what was vital in recreating this image
has now gone and we're not going to get
it back and in fact that's exactly what
you do see so if we show the actual
output here we can see that our see is
kind of visible but it's been completely
dwarfed by all this random noise that's
been added